[Musica]
[Applauso]
no
ad esempio si sa da rockstar nostro
tempo è diventato un incubo meccanizzato
abbiamo perso la capacità di sentire
l'armonia del colore che abbiamo
spezzato dobbiamo parcellizzato ed è
questo che ci procura infelicità
quella fisica quantistica non facciamo a
te confermare quello che era stato detto
da millenni buckley
e noi nava che si sta separavo per poco
tutto è un'unica cosa
a noi sembra frazionata nel tempo e
nello spazio ma è un'illusione
bene realizzare alcuni dei miei film
documentari ho avuto la fortuna di
incontrare alcuni di questi popoli
popoli ancestrali che vivono in angoli
nascosti del mondo gli aborigeni in
australia i nativi d'america di pianure
del nord america i popoli della
mesoamerica che vivono in centro america
e nel sud america popoli che con umiltà
possono ancora insegnarci tantissime
cose legate all'ecologia esempio loro ci
ricorda non ci dicono che ne trattiamo
la terra come se ci fosse stata donata
da un genitore è come se dopo di noi non
ci fosse nessuno mentre loro ci
ricordano che il loro modo di vivere a
terra e come quella di qualcuno che ha
preso la terra in prestito da un figlio
e che poi dovrà di istituirla ma io dico
nella trovata e pensate come stiamo
trattando nella terra se ci facessero
questa domanda cosa
restituiamo noi ai nostri figli tra 50
anni
siamo sicuri di avere la coscienza a
posto probabilmente no e quindi credo
che questi popoli con semplicità apposta
neuer insegnarci qualcosa e vorrei in
qualche modo ci condividere con voi
alcune storiche che ho avuto modo di
vivere quando passato il tempo con loro
per esempio questo ragazzo
opi nativo americano quando lo ha
intervistato ha detto io ho provato a
vivere come voi ma poi fate cose
veramente troppo strane esempio comprate
l'acqua in bottiglia
io grazie
mia cugina lo ha portato a posta e e
quindi quando ha detto questa cosa un po
è un po stupido e quindi ho fatto una
piccola ricerca e ha detto ma quanta
acqua consumiamo ho scoperto che vengono
prodotte un milione di bottiglie di
plastica ogni minuto che ci faremmo
tutta questa plastica spesso purtroppo
viene gettata e finisce nelle isole
artificiali di plastica che stanno man
mano occupando i nostri oceani isole
grandi quanto la francia pensato una
volta ho fatto un viaggio nell'isola di
pasqua tra l'altro il nome isola di
pasqua è stato dato dal scopritore al
conquistatore olandese che nel 1722 è
andato a scoprire quest'isola
ma non è che si è preoccupato di
chiedere a chi ci abitava come si
chiamava la chiamata l'isola di pasqua
perché ha scoperte al giorno di pasqua
pensate che fantasia 200 anni dopo il
cile si è ricordato di gara a chi ci
viveva
qual era il loro nome è l'anno di nuovo
chiamata rapa nui poi sul discorso i
nomi ci torneremo ma è un elemento
importante per far capire qual è la
nostra visione del mondo e approccio nei
confronti delle altre culture comunque e
stando lì chi abita quest'isola trapanoi
sta attento molto attento a fare la
differenziata ea rispettare l'ambiente
nonostante questo moltissime coste di
quest'isola sono invase da questa
plastica non è ovviamente la loro
plastica e la plastica del mondo
continuando a parlare con questo ragazzo
mi ha detto un vanto delle cose che io
non sono riuscito a sopportare della
vostra città e il senso di isolamento
che avevo vivendoci pensateci
noi viviamo in città spesso con migliaia
e migliaia di abitanti in condomini con
centinaia di persone ma non conosciamo
nessuno
abbiamo un senso di isolamento
percettivo che probabilmente la causa
del male di oggi della depressione che
dire oggi l'occidente pensate che
l'aumento costante di persone di sotto
di pressione depressione ormai un
problema sociale consigliamo 300
cinquanta milioni di antidepressivi nel
mondo in occidente
ovviamente questo è sintomatico di
qualcosa che non sta funzionando
nella nostra società il nostro vivere
lui poi ha continuato dicendo ma il
senso del noi che io vivo in questa
comunità non vedono soltanto perché vivo
insieme alla comunità con cui condivido
tutto lo vivo perché io mi sento parte
di qualcosa anche stando in mezzo alla
natura
pensate che loro iniziano le cerimonie
dicendo omat a cugliate a tutte le
nostre infinite relazioni ma
infiltrazioni non sono quella cucina la
suocera si sa sono le azioni che hanno
con tutto ciò che li circonda
col fiume con l'albero o la pianta
perché tutto è attivo tutto è connesso
infatti loro seguono in qualche modo
sono ispirati al grande spirito wakan
pack grande mistero mistero perché sanno
che c'è vita in tutte le cose e se c'è
vita in tutte le cose
io rispetto tutto ciò che esiste perché
l'uomo è parte di questo tutto non è
sopra a questo tutto ed è quindi questa
visione che in qualche modo noi oggi
dobbiamo riconquistare questa visione di
connessione la stiamo riscoprendo
attraverso la scienza oggi la fisica
quantistica ci insegna che tutto ti bra
che tutto è vivo ma un conto e biberon
attraverso la scienza un conto è piccolo
perché lo senti e sono cose che noi
sapevamo ma ci stiamo dimenticando ci
siamo dimenticati
pensate 500 anni fa per il neo galilei
diceva le cose sono unite da legami
invisibili non puoi cogliere un fiore
senza turbare una stella che fine ha
fatto questo sapienza abbiamo perso
e la ritroveremo sia ricominciamo ad
ascoltare questi popoli
questi popoli che stanno lì che ci
dimentichiamo spesso anche il nome una
volta nel grand canyon ho assistito a
questa scena un omone un macchinone
bianco che si ferma dove c'era una donna
che stava svelando un cavallo e questo
omone chiede a questa donna ei ma voi
indiani che tecnica usata per stellare i
cavalli
a quel punto lei se lo guarda dritto
negli occhi
poi si guarda a destra si guarda a
sinistra lo riguarda e ricomincia a fare
quello che faceva con lo scià lance
tranquilla lui ha indispettito dice ma
mi sta prendendo in giro
insiste e ripete ma voi indiani che
tecnica usate per sera del cavallo
sto parlando con te non proprio così
perché parlava inglese
a quel punto lei se lo riguarda si
riporta a destra ci riguarda a sinistra
ricordo ha detto negli occhi con uno
sguardo che soltanto chi vive nel
deserto con lo sguardo perforante e poi
dice scusa non pensavo parlarsi con me
io qui non ho visto nessun indiano
iniziale in stallo in india io sono uno
che sono un di ne sono molte altre cose
ma non sono di certo un indiano e
pensate che noi continuiamo a chiamarla
indiani che colombo 500 anni fa ha
sbagliato strada
arrivato in un continente ha cominciato
a chiamare le persone indiani e
cinquecento anni dopo noi continuiamo a
chiamarmi così neanche il nome gli diamo
capite quanto è importante oggi a ridare
il loro ruolo a queste persone
queste persone sono veramente i custodi
della madre terra della pachamama come
la chiamano loro
il centro america nel circa america
bolivia ecuador hanno fatto una legge in
cui hanno messo nella costituzione
una carta dei diritti della terra una
carta che riconosce la terra come essere
vivente
noi abbiamo scoperto questa cosa
scientificamente attraverso la teoria di
gaia di love e lo avete come noi
arriviamo a comprendere certe cose
sempre attraverso la scienza michael
sentire michael sentire che cambiano che
cambiano le cose perché cambiamo la
nostra percezione il nostro senso di
connessione evo morales nel 2009 ha
portato questo concetto alle nazioni
unite
da lì ha cominciato a crearsi molti
movimenti lo stesso ho fatto tre tour
chiamati pachamama manifesto per la
madre terra in cui ho cercato di portare
alle opinioni pubbliche ai comuni la
filosofia quanto possa essere importante
riconoscere i diritti di un fiume
i diritti di un albero e diritti della
terra ma penso anche che oggi è giunto
il momento in cui l'uomo non ha più
bisogno di una legge per salvare il
pianeta perché probabilmente neanche con
le leggi facciamo più in tempo è giunto
momento in cui l'uomo deve riconoscere
se dentro se stesso che le cose devono
cambiare e se voi oggi siete qui è
perché quel fuoco dentro ce l'avete e
quindi ognuno di noi nelle piccole cose
quotidiane o cambiare il mondo e quello
che lasceremo alle prossime generazioni
io nel mio piccolo ho fatto un ufficio
in campagna o faccio faccio l'orto non
sono ancora bravissimo ma migliorerà
cerco di fare film che trattano queste
tematiche e quindi io il mio piccolo
cerco di dare il mio contributo
ognuno di noi nel suo piccolo può dare
il suo contributo ram si diceva
quand'ero giovane volevo cambiare il
mondo
ora che sono saggio voglio cambiare me
stesso
il mondo lo cambieremo se cambieremo noi
stessi delle piccole scelte quotidiane
grazie
kat